Narrator: As you might
imagine, World War I was
one of the bloodiest events in, frankly,
all of human history.
I was thinking about
putting some pictures here,
and I encourage you to do a web search
for actual photographs from World War I
of mass graves and people starving
and soldiers dead in trenches.
It will make you feel ill.
It's probably a good
thing to look for those
images because it will
remind you how disgusting
and gross and crazy wars can be.
Sometimes we abstract
it when we look at it
in hindsight and we just
talk about the numbers.
World War I was gruesome,
especially because this
was the first time that
industrialized weapons
were really put to use in a war context.
There was far more bloodshed
than I think any of the
fighting powers actually
believed there would be.
Just to put things in to numbers,
and these are huge numbers,
and these are frankly
abstract numbers; numbers that are hard
for us to comprehend.
We don't know the exact numbers,
as you can imagine, it's
not easy to take a census.
The military's have a better count of
who might have been killed
or who might be missing.
The civilian casualties are
almost impossible to count.
You have people who are
inadvertently killed
by a bomb, you have people who are dying
of starvation, who are
dying due to famine.
These are very hard numbers to count,
but there is some consensus on the rough
estimates on the total
casualties in World War I.
In particular, I'm going to
focus here on the deaths,
when people talk about
casualties that often will also
talk about injured.
Just the deaths alone,
the estimates I've seen,
and I encourage you to look up your own
and try to figure out what
consensus you could get to,
but the estimates I've
seen have on the order of
16 million, million deaths during
or due to World War I.
If we were to break down those deaths,
we have 8-10 million in the military.
So, directly military these
are death of soldiers,
so this is the military.
It was roughly, based on
the accounts that I've seen,
about 60% of these deaths were amongst
the Entente, and about 40% were amongst
the central powers, but in either case,
we're talking about
millions on either side
of World War I and then the rest,
if we're talking on the
order of about 6-7 million
were civilians.
(writing) 6-7 millions civilians.
The estimates I've seen
were about 1 million plus
that were directly due to military action.
This is military action
impacting civilians.
This was disproportionately
felt on the side
of the Entente, on the side of the allies.
If you look at where,
especially the western front
was fought, it becomes clear
and also much of where the
eastern front was fought.
The eastern front, a lot of it was fought
on Russian land, or what
was controlled by the
Russian Empire at the time
and on the western front,
much of the, or most of
the battle was in France
and in Belgium and also in Italy,
that was also where you
had a significant amount
of the battle actually going on.
So, this is why the allies, the Entente,
felt a disproportionate
number of the civilian
that's directly due to
military casualties.
But then on top of that, the
rest of the civilian count,
this is what's, frankly,
very hard to get an exact
number on, this would be due to famine,
starvation, disease.
(writing) disease.
We've talked before about the blockade
of the central powers.
You had definitely
people not being able to
kind of eat properly,
you had the Spanish Flu.
It was just an all around ugly situation
and then to make matters worse,
and this is what the
history books often forget,
you often had an explicit extermination
of peoples' trying to
happen during World War I.
In fact, the, I guess, most notable,
but often forgotten was
the Armenian genocide.
There was actually an explicit campaign
on the part of the Ottoman's
and this actually started
before World War I, but
it kind of hit full pace
during World War I where 1 to ...
I've seen estimates of
1 million to 1.5 million
Armenian's were systematically ...
I'm talking about men, women, children,
systematically killed by
the Ottoman government.
War is ugly and it brings out the worst
in people and you see it
just from these numbers.
Just to give a context of all this is ...
it's very easy for us just
to abstract these things,
but I really wanted to sit
in how horrible this was,
but just to kind of
bring it all into focus.
This right here is a passage from
The Atlantic Monthly, Volume
129 that was published
in 1922 and it's a passage
on Joseph Tumulty's book.
Joseph Tumulty was the Private Secretary,
what is now called the Chief of Staff,
of President Woodrow Wilson.
This is about his account of being with
Woodrow Wilson after the war was declared
in World War I.
It's fascinating because
it applies, frankly,
to most wars, or all wars.
The War President and the War.
"At the time of delivering his far-echoed
"war message, in April
1917, the President was
"cheered by dense multitudes
thronging the streets
"as he passed from the
White House to the Capital
"and back again.
"This is from Tumulty's,"
that's Woodrow Wilson's
Chief of Staff, or it was
called Private Secretary then.
"This is from Tumulty's own description
of the return: 'For a while he,'"
and we're talking about Woodrow Wilson,
"'For a while, he sat silent and pale in
"'the Cabinet room.
"'At last he said, 'Think what it was they
"'were applauding.'"
"'My message today was a message of death
"'for our young men.
"'How strange it seems to applaud that.'"